sorry guys I'm holding a microphone at
the same time
just a couple photo ops and we're gonna
get the stream going guys
this is the Gator and elunatan
seriously though welcome everyone I know
you guys were eating in ether the land
of something it took a minute you know
we're here we're compiling ourselves and
I even said we got to start it we almost
didn't start it yet because we were
taking photos and stuff but I thought
that could be he's fun to see us taking
photos and things but he's as you can
see chatting I'm gonna give him this mic
soon we'll chitchat
we're here at movies the grand opening
I've already eaten my cow tipper tater
tots
so good I just had some cookies that
might have chocolate all over my face
but anyway we're here guys you guys get
to see this because people can really
come in and hang out well you guys get
to come in and hang out you can pick up
food and such as of tomorrow I believe
is that right as of tomorrow as of
tomorrow they can pick up food yeah so
but but you guys yes so you get him
you can order now though you can order
now and all that but tomorrow's the day
gets start picking things up and getting
the food and trying it for so but the
cool thing is my point is you're here
now with us and no one gets to see this
really because you can't come and sit
down it's a whole new it's a whole new I
don't have my mask on but you know
quarantine life now yeah that's from
twitch sings I'm practicing so I'm
getting a little better you know I'm
saying yeah guys so we're doing I'm
doubling it up but again in a minute
you'll have more someone you guys see me
all day you saw me earlier playing games
we did a little twitch things for a
second we did some Friday the 13th which
is so much fun
Josh you got to come and play some point
because josh is who's behind the camera
can't see him but he plays video games
he plays and streams on YouTube and such
but you know I've been running around as
Jason and trying to take out as many
people as possible in the game in real
life not so much I run around and try to
hug people and it's weird but but yeah
man let's say I guess Oh cuz we can go a
little bit distance I guess is it weird
if I'm talking here will it be weird
because it's doubling up get the young
lady behind you I'm just kidding we
could start outside though let's go do I
got two mics two likes him come on
outside I'm on my twitch but there's a
Harley Quinn everyone introduce
yourselves real quick sorry I'm Austin's
asier hello twitch I'm a part of Rio you
might have seen the two of them in
reboot and this gentleman here is a star
you will you're gonna see him in scary
stories to tell in the dark
yeah there you have it and son son in
lockdown that's the other one but let's
come out here and let them get by but
they're going inside this is the outside
this is the outdoor eatery if you will
there is a sitting area outside here
where I I don't know but it's just for
today the outside I know inside your kid
you can't come and eat inside but I
don't know maybe outside you're allowed
to come and sit because they even have
it chalked off perfectly to this chalk
mark for that stats face this is that
space here's the walkway six feet apart
and all that good stuff so we'll see
we'll see but tomorrow's the day guys
but you can start going online right now
movies I believe it's movies.com forward
slash pop-up or something it's on my
stream my stream labs ID can give you
that you can hear beats out here while
you're eating your cow tipper sorry so
that's it this is a year I wish we could
were wired so we can't really walk
around but with that's the entrance
there too
and we can go in there and there's a
there's a little spot where we have
merchandise which we've shown well they
get show more but let's go inside it's a
little chaotic here for what we're doing
but I thought this could be fun so we'll
see
nice
I love that setup guys all right guys
the camera don't be don't be scared by
the rocks that I got Josh's jet now josh
is moving the camera inside again you
get sort of see we could start here
movies you know a little spot to come in
and take photos at the window as if
you're working the window of movies that
is this gentleman has been taking photos
with us how many years 2015 at least yes
since clerks man since clerks he's been
taking pictures he's been goes to all
the events private events the premieres
all that stuff say your full name so I
don't mess it up my name is albert el
ortega but you can call me out there you
have it so yeah man forever and ever and
ever and then you move over here we got
a little quick you guys should have
masks on I'm just kidding
reboot remember reboot where she was
like crying and I'm just kidding not so
much that bad
no she was great they were great that is
the quick stop groceries so you take
photos in front of the quick stops with
the shutters I assure you were open the
gum in the locks all that good stuff
I been glebe is taking up Kevin time
Thank You Levi love your face bro but
you're taking up kevin time he's he's
got live facebook hey kids
obviously we're having a little shindig
social distancing shindig here at the
very first night of movies the movies
pop up so much to tell you but Ben Gleib
is here you know Ben Gleib of course he
before John Oliver called his show last
week tonight rue glebe created a show
that I thought was one of the most
brilliantly named not just podcasts but
the media shows in general called last
week on earth such a great title
catchy in so many ways you also known
from Jane Tom Bob reboot I was telling
him before that every night of the tour
I saw him you know throw J a gun and
then J go dude this guns fake and he
goes why would it be real and every
night it got a laugh stuff so you know
gleep gleep has a great story about like
how the you know everyone have went into
quarantine and necessity being the
mother of invention he created something
that's legit tell them what you did well
when your backs against the wall you
either do something to get out or you
get smashed I don't wanna get smashed no
unless I'm the right amount of drunk and
then maybe it's a fun night yes which
you could be at movies by the way
commercial commercial fact we sell beer
right now a capri-sun pouch that is not
made soft I'll tell you that much it is
heavy pork we go hard indeed so so how
you can tell he's a comic that's how he
makes his living he goes out there in
the world he stands in front of people
live says funny things
unfortunately we fell into a period
where nobody could do that the folk
fellow like glib can't go ply his trade
because and who knows when he'll be able
to plies trade again because we don't
know when they're letting audiences sit
in so bleed back against the wall comes
up with a great idea tell them what you
did so comedy clubs shut down around the
world live entertainment shut down for
the planet I thought how can I create a
comedy club online completely so I
created with my friend Steve Hofstetter
the world's first fully virtual comedy
club called the nowhere comedy club
because that is where it is and through
zoom but we have a special way that we
produce it and we have showroom managers
and bouncers and we have security
protocols so you can have a full comedy
club experience in your living room you
buy a ticket and you see your favorite
comedians your favorite podcast your
favorite entertainers live in your house
your cameras on your mic is on you get
to laugh they hear you you hear them
it's a completely interactive experience
where everybody watching gets to have
for the first time a comedy clip in your
own home and so if you can't afford to
go to a club if you have social anxiety
disabilities or you're just lazy as [ __ ]
we come to you and you get to see your
favorite comics perform live
one-time-only performance private
performance in your house that's where
your palm let me tell you something rich
people and I mean rich people like
billionaires outside the industry hire
other rich people to do on command
command performances for their kids or
Mitzvah or something like that where
you'll read a story we were like Beyonce
went and did a show for like a hundred
people why and it was for a billionaire
that's called a prince and Dubai exactly
and they have that kind of money this is
your opportunity to be like bring a star
any to my living room star since movies
there you go so look at that it's wider
here you get the see baby Kevin look at
this all this stuff and more sorry got
our mics in your face we're here and I
know I was sitting here like trying to
jump in your story but was if we can't
jump in their story I know
isn't that a great idea it sounds like
RP almost they have a thing ja grand
theft auto RP like where people go in
and roleplay and become characters and
they could talk to each other it's
almost like that but in a comedy setting
it sounds awesome we're gonna check this
out on my twitch we're gonna come to a
show man either me and him or me and
Ralph have him write me lines let me ask
you something I know you can't talk
about it but how wait I don't know
they haven't I don't know the world
seems to know but I don't know if this
has been made official and so do you do
you watch the mandalorian let's start
there watch the mandalorian that season
that show is amazing and I hope one day
to get cast on it that would be
incredible so - wouldn't it be amazing
total thing online about this so I'm
just I try not to jinx it but if it does
happen it's because of everyone and all
of you who've been for years now
actually pushing for it and when the
mandalorian came out and we did the math
and saw the age I was like well I could
realize my dreams of playing this young
amazing character who's now my age that
is astounding I remember having a
conversation with you a long time ago
about like man if there was and how neat
that we live in a world where it could
be a thing again I mean you know I am
okay with being a little greedy in this
world I already in the DC Universe I'm
in the Marvel Universe that's all you've
been Wonder Woman you've been Batgirl
that's a lot but if I could also be in
Star Wars and I don't end it there if I
could also be on Star Trek and that's it
that's like drop the mic stuff I can
retire I'll be great my daughter will be
happy I'd be home more because there
will be nothing else for me to do
also a franchise what what have you been
doing man since the last time I saw you
pop up was I was going through the
channels on on iTunes and double-tap
came out what have you been working on
before the world went into hiding and
stuff are you working on a flick oh I
mean crazily I just wrapped this pilot
with Ava Duvernay based off of DMZ the
DMZ comic the DC property and you know
that takes place that's saying that
there is not a concession of power that
this in this election what you know in
cities like 2020 and we go into a civil
war and New Jersey becomes part of the
free states as you know and in the comic
and it was just you know we're shooting
it there was a lot of hypotheticals and
energy around it but I think it has a
completely different context from when
we wrapped filming it and we were
already going into we were one of the
last productions to shut down and into
now being able to have just watched the
first to see it yesterday okay it's it's
just the the impact of it from when I
read this good from when I read the
comic to now watching it be realized it
just lands completely different and I
can't tell you how prescient it is I
just can't as you described it I'm like
oh my god like the timing couldn't be
better
what is she like to work as she was
directing ava is amazing her her
emotional intelligence her communication
her presence her energy her passion her
sophistication her it comes across in
her tweets that she's a different kind
of individual she's very very special
she's the one of the top best directors
I have ever worked with in life and I
really hope that you get a chance to
work with her because she's really
really special human being I we we
passed each other in a tweet at one
point but she's I like her style
I like the decisions she makes and also
a lot of people I know know her and they
all vouch are you being one of them
she's also working on a like a superhero
thing
or word not right now but was gearing up
to do new gods and stuff like that and
it sounds like you know we know her from
stuff like salma stuff like the Netflix
stuff that she's done and what you just
described what is that called the DMZ so
she's already got one foot with that in
comic book arena yes and it was amazing
to see her do I mean she's you know this
was a huge production I mean we have
explosions all these kinds of things
going on and this was some of this was
at a bit of a territory with some of the
way that we shot this that she hadn't
really explored before in other projects
and so it was just really amazing to see
how she just brought it all together and
shined and you know it's a pilot so
crossing your fingers HBO max picks it
up you know it's it's also so much has
changed now and it's a bit a bit more on
the expensive side of a show to shoot so
I could see that maybe potentially being
something but she's really confident and
I'm really confident and I think we need
this kind of storytelling right now I
think the fact that we're ready to jump
right in into this conversation with
this property I think is so important
how does he not get picked up right now
yeah so that's where that's where we're
at right now what what are you most
looking forward to doing as the world
reopens and stuff what have you missed
my boyfriend's what do you mean he is by
himself between going between New York
I mean Newark and in DC and I
why are you socially distancing from one
another because I've been taking care of
my parents I'm actually in the process
of moving by the way I'm going to New
Jersey with mom because you know it's
time but and we were thinking about
moving in together anyway but especially
during all of this it's just been do you
know that's what my family came from
everyone in my family came from Newark
really yeah I'm very excited I mean it's
you know my dad home inaudible yes and
he would you helped bring there but it's
you know been several months now since
my dad had his cancer surgery he has was
diagnosed with pancreatic cancer early
last year
and he had a surgery in November and
he's still cancer-free now but he's
still under 130 pounds and he's six foot
one so it's just been it's the reason
why I've just been super careful and
really is kind of distant from everyone
and and that's why it's just about like
I don't feel like we're going to be a
bicoastal kind of you know kind of
country for a while so I think it's just
I'm just gonna be East Coast so that I
can minimize any opportunity chances of
Cavanaugh being separated again
when was the last time he spent that
much time on the East Coast not for work
from New York I saw my nine one seven I
have a lot of people that really that I
still live there so I just brought
property upstate as well so still have
my New York place we have you know I
have my fashion line Studio 189 and made
these masks we're based in Ghana and we
have our place in Brooklyn so it's just
gonna be good I mean they're my brothers
they're it's just you know again I
travel I always said I live on a plane
the ball for the past 15 years and
that's just not possible to do anymore
so I'm just I'm actually really excited
to go back home the we were before the
whole world closed for the quarantine we
were on tour with Jay and Silent Bob
reboot so I was there I went to every
show every night and I got to see like
every night when you opened the door and
Jesse the crowd go nuts and like applaud
and [ __ ] like that and so one thing for
them to see you and be like oh my god
she's here we're happy she's at the
party but then you brought the house
down with your with your like [ __ ]
like mister come quick thumb dick your
delivery of it so like high-pitched like
it's somebody about to laugh crushed was
an audience applause moment and then
there was something I saw every night
which I always appreciated weird a shot
where you know we're saying goodbye on
the curb and in the foreground
Shannon Elizabeth's getting into the
vehicle and she's talking to Jack and in
the background you're getting into the
driver's side and you stand up on the
ledge and you go like this and 25 to 30
percent of the audience every night
would laugh in that moment
found it man like I edited it on a small
screen we were kind of like race to get
that last shot and so I'm really glad
it's a cameo and I tried to milk it as
much as possible and I appreciated the
fact that you did you were just like I'm
gonna put everything I can I love you as
well I can't believe you come to this
man oh my god I mean I literally don't
even leave it this is like I left the
house yesterday if you saw my bat mo
Prius because I wrapped my Prius in
matte black and I have it it says bat mo
Prius in the back it's literally got
cobwebs on it that's how much I've
literally just thank you for coming so
glad for this chance to come out and my
mom has ordered a vegan burger so I'll
be home with me yes all right I'm gonna
give you back to him I'm gonna go are
you taking it can we take a picture with
who's gonna who's gonna do your show I
could still be here well I would love to
get a picture tube already yeah oh well
they'll just say mush
da-da-dah we're gonna go take a picture
me J Rosario
so we're gonna leave you with Aparna
posting for a minute Aparna was in Jay
and Silent Bob reboot played jihad
Aparna you take over hosting for a
minute
very buzz oh god hi even better
we are sorry Oh Dawson and Kevin Flynn
all right you do that I don't know what
I'm doing oh okay
so we're live right now okay okay cool
um Mike oh my god I'm so scared right
now
Harley help me okay yeah I'm gonna wait
for my my best friend Harley Quinn Smith
to come join me what should I wear my
mask oh okay AJ's twitch I know he
spends a lot of time on twitch so it's
good to be here
what Reba was a great experience
yeah we sacrificed a lot of things to
Satan yeah did we we were in New Orleans
that's what you do yeah
it was a good time it was fantastic call
me now we're here and this house
coronavirus everyone is it good are you
having a fine god I hate it
oh and here we have a photo op if you
want to seek that place Wow look at them
they're so cute you guys are
look at them they're very cute you're
not pulling it look how cute look at
that bone structure look at that bone
structure think that's a great bone
structure those cheek bones bad so
where's my mom going
Jen I mean we could send Austin after
her that's why I'm not running away
oh I'm her I though it was just a whole
lot of filler videos to two girls just
hanging out this is just us hanging to
movies can't really look so scary your
mask looks so scary it makes your eyes
look scary I'll talk about my kittens
[Music]
I have two kittens yeah sorry guys we're
taking pic we're trying to get pictures
of for Rosaria leaves around movies cuz
you know she's lying to Connor
I thought they'd be great to feel like
as his cousin's daughter I've known her
forever this is my stream and dad stream
first about your like we hear about dad
all the time at home and what's going on
I wonder your perspective because you
used to go out and do music with your
friends and go out and do a bunch of
stuff you were I feel like we used to go
out and do a lot of things and now
you're home so luckily you got your
kittens your rabbit yes I have a rabbit
awesome and she's she's got a friend
that comes over hangs out really
I like somebody come work Kevin
both of them
this one this one alright look no one
can handle the me show bro bright I
asked someone to take the book heaven
can but I see now why a point I didn't
want to talk on my camera cuz look at
her she's like EEE fair enough this is
my show anyway anyway the other one
anyway guys I think that was a special
special little treat
I did not expect or know that rosario
was coming and you missed it's a bummer
he left oh and I'm sorry I always
butcher his name David dashing now and
he's on MacGyver he plays Murdoch we're
getting awesome hears and yeah it's like
what a treat we have all these people
have stopped by very cool and you guys
get to see witness here you get the
witness movies opening or the inside of
movies I was hanging out Kevin coming
and chit-chatting Ben Gleib when his
story about his virtual comedy club
rosario pulled out it's very sweet I'm
getting real sweaty with this mask on
so you know what guys you know let's do
this while the mics are like the mics
are plunk it out a little bit and it's
probably easier for you Josh can you why
you said why don't you walk around and
give him a little we haven't we haven't
even gone over to the movies or
something so do you mind walking just
give him a little POV of of that and
then and then I could like regroup over
here check-in all right guys so if
you're gonna go so I don't know if that
Josh don't have to worry about me
following him and tripping over wires
and stuff
ominous he's gonna go show you the store
the clip stop rst video merchandise the
menu for movies all the good stuff and
you'll be right back right here and you
know we'll see what's what's next in the
works
check when hey we got a mind
sorry guys technical difficulty check
one
yeah whichever ones this
I need them
Jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
here's here's what we're doing
[Music]
well folks were having a wonderful time
here at the my name is Julian Julian
Mowatt with Kevin Smith we're having a
wonderful time here at the movies pop up
and the food is amazing
I mean the setup is outstanding you feel
like you're out of standalone movies but
at the same time you're at the kiosk in
the mall in Mallrats so definitely come
and check it out it's a once in a
lifetime experience and you know just
eat your heart out - these are tough
times eat the tots eat the burgers eat
the chicken eat the onion rings at the
brownies it's vegan for some of you who
have stricter diets which means
healthier - God knows I need a healthier
diet so just go for it guys get some
cocktails - while you're at it
drink up it's time to it's about time
that we all start drinking up a little
bit in these
Chelsea
Chelsea
what am I supposed to do
[Music]
I'm Chelsea Cole I was an Associate
Producer on reboot I work for Kevin
full-time this is the amazing movies
pop-up it's beautiful it's wonderful I
love it
Kevin and rosario in the background I
mean can you get any better than that
no okay
the food is amazing so if you're going
to come to the pop-up I highly recommend
it I am vegan so the beyond me
burgers are like the best and the onion
rings phenomenal so I highly highly
recommend the movies pop not because I
work for them but because it is very
very good so coming in our food thanks
Hey
just wipe down the mics a little bit
yeah
have you guys done it do you need to do
a tour
[Music]
okay all right let me put this down
mask off are we ready
okay so we walk this way not much
further right here you'll see this is
where you can get all your food all of
your merch you have a chainsaw reboot
t-shirts we've got hater tots t-shirts
we've got movies t-shirts we've got
movies masks
we've got everything that you could
possibly need for the current events
going on including the drinks and then
if you turn this way it feels like
you're in the mall
you've got movie saying right here it
looks like you could pick up your order
right there totally decked out and it
kind of looks like to be movie street
art if you will you got your quick stop
they assure you they're open and then
you've got the rst video Home
Entertainment to get all of your films
every single Star Wars on VHS guaranteed
and don't forget popular girl you can go
to the back and you'll see you'll have
to wait for mr. Shannon Hamilton that is
a fact
believe me you do not want to have to
wait for mr. Shannon Hamilton not the
best but when you get here I mean what
would I recommend getting it's a hard
say listen the burger is gonna be good
if you're vegan or not the vegan burger
is gonna be good if you're vegan around
they have regular but I would go vegan I
mean I have the vegan burger and it was
bomb like absolutely bomb the hater tots
how could you not get hair ties I mean
hater tots in my mind are better than
tater tots they're more of a national
symbol than tater tots are I think it's
the more important to have your hater
tots a daily dose of hater tots
you know like four ounces or so like
what the doctor recommends
and then when you're choosing between
the fill the cop of the screwdriver or
the margarita hmm I mean margarita is
summertime you want to have a lighter
drink you want to feel a little cooled
out in tequila just does the trick if
you ask me
and then always end with the brownie
it's not for everybody because it's not
vegan if you're vegan get the cookie but
the brownie guys let me tell you this is
one of those treat your kids take it
home to your mom kind of brownies you
put a little bit ice cream on there if
you take it to go or you just eat it by
itself here and you feel like it's the
whole meal I'm gonna get another brownie
I don't know about you but I mean it's
just so good
[Music]
hmm I told myself I wouldn't do it too
but I'll try it work it off tomorrow
superb
really good really really good you
seriously cannot make these at home even
if you like burnt your fingers trying to
make them which I did yesterday now
trying to make brownies but literally
trying to make chicken like you just
can't make these at home they're way
better than anything that you would find
at home at the grocery store at a bakery
there's just something to be said about
a pop-up fast-food brownie it's like the
perfect amount of salt flour not almond
flour just regular flour I think I have
no clue
chocolate sugar although it doesn't
taste it's too sugary I would say it's
more
you know it's just a little savory
yeah let's ask them what they think
that's gone guys can only go so far but
what's it been like working at the
movies pop-up it's been great this is
day one I think everything has gone
pretty smooth tried the food I have it's
amazing the chef's kill it
what's your favorite chicken sandwich
top smoker what's your favorite out the
vegan the vegan mood tipper okay and
what would you say for anybody that's
looking to come here during the pandemic
you know interested just passes by like
what would you do to really learn them
in I mean I don't know what other
restaurant you're gonna go to and get an
experience like this I mean from the
from the decorations to the food to me
it's kind of a complete package
[Music]
McDonald's right couldn't agree more
what'd it say you if you're a real fan
boy this is the ultimate experience come
get all the experiences for clerks the
reboot any movie stuff coming out with
the real Dante and Randall it's a good
time you guys will love it don't fear
the co vid you got masks you guys can
wear when you get here
a lot of merch the food is vegan as well
as regular food vegan is really way
better though don't get it you heard it
here first I'm eating it that's what
they say
hmm I'm sorry I just can't get enough of
the brownie it's so good you guys have
more of the brownie my can I take some
home yeah
Jordan I'd love you to interview if
you're comfortable interviewing because
I'm not good at it over again for Kevin
but interview Jordans friends who have
they're doing some good stuff around
here I can absolutely do the so it looks
like I'm double-fisting here it's just
temporarily but yeah absolutely
ladies and gentlemen we're about to have
an exclusive interview I don't know if
you're ready for it I don't think you're
ready for it but I have here this
Diamond Jones you I can I mean I can
[Laughter]
everybody this is miss diamond Jones she
is with cleanup south-central yes a
newly found organization that is
dedicated to helping the community of
South LA now diamond everything going on
in the world obviously inspired you to
really kind of start this organization
but what like what really drove it home
for you for South Central I did a couple
of things for a local
last year so we gave back about like 75
pairs shoes we gave 100 haircuts so I
think it was just more solemn just like
just doing what I love to do I love to
get back get back and I think it just
turned into it like bigger than what I
expected so I don't know it's just me
wanted to get back that's amazing man
yeah honestly like the things that have
been going on the world they've been
happening the past couple weeks like
what would you say has changed in your
perspective as not only a black person
but as a black woman I know guys I'm
sorry we're getting a little deep here
at movies that's what the brownies do I
had one too many brownies being a lot
more power to to actually really make
changes and to do something about I
don't think we've ever had I mean we've
had it but I don't think to this level
to where actual laws legislation is even
in like corporate America people are
getting fired like it's a real real
thing going on right now so I think just
us like sharing our voices has been very
powerful yeah yeah and then so you
started the cleanup the first cleanup
that was after the initial protest
happening in South LA right what's the
goal like what would you say is the
overall go goal for South LA is it gonna
be beyond South away or
now is to really make a change
healthier grocery stores better schools
like better-looking communities fixing
up abandoned buildings I think it's more
than just like cleaned up streets for me
I think it's more of like actually doing
the work and like really getting in
there and clean it up so essentially
making it better outside of you know
just cleaning up streets I really want
to get in get in there and like actually
make real changes trying out here that's
all any of us can do during this time
and reporting here from West Hollywood
at look ray and Santa Monica it's Julian
closing it out with Diamond Jones you
know she's the og honestly she's like
actually killing it for the community
she's only 28 y'all she's only 28
killing it for the community killing it
for the movement seriously honestly I
would say a symbol and an icon to a lot
of people in LA right now because we
don't have that and that's something
that we need I'm not I'm from Chicago
but I've been here six years
ten year market then I can say I'm an
Angelina but I'm not an Angelina just
yet
give me another four years I'll be there
I feel like one but not yet not yet once
I hit my for you I still have so much
more exploring of the city to do and
that has me come to my next question
we're in South LA should I go for some
of the best food I can get other than
movies you know I gotta open up the
movies we're opening up the movies in
Inglewood
okay
[Music]
freshen meetings we have a lot of like
[Laughter]
and while movies not the healthiest it's
got some of the best foods and all the
proceeds will be going to clean up South
Central so diamond thank you thank you
for partnering with us and now I'm gonna
hand it off to our leader our Father my
mentor mr. Kevin Smith and I'm sure he
interviewed the heck out of you how
surprised were you though when you were
alive when 300 people showed up as
opposed to a handful is that what it was
[Music]
I couldn't take a picture for you to see
in that moment where you like oh we
could do this more than once how amazing
and how fast it all came together
transformative it makes you that like in
a world where you're like wow this
worked out why not head into the schools
what would be after that where does one
keep going
we have a lot of buildings I think just
making the city better I mean if I could
be that one person not to leave that be
careful man they might elect you to
something you know if you show that you
could change things people expect you to
keep going and going how much of what
you do in the day job helped with clean
up South Central at all
when I heard the story cuz Jordan who
runs our company was like I read this
article wouldn't she be great to like
we're gonna donate work locally this
seems like a really cool thing I read
the article and I was you know two
things one like wow that's awesome
second one was wow I'm a piece of [ __ ]
because it didn't occur to me like never
occurred to me like watches you want to
help pick up a rake pick up a broom
whatever the hell that's super heroic
stuff right there man no mask no cape
and still looking to make a difference
the idea of like a superhero and in the
comic books and stuff that grew up on is
you know the whole world is running from
the worst thing that ever happened you
see one person running toward it you're
that one person right now who's running
toward the problem as opposed to boy
from it so thank you for that and thank
you for letting us in some way come in
and help out man that's
[Music]
all right well we're here to help
amen amen thank you so much I'm gonna go
meet your mom in a minute when we're all
done man I think it's adorable that you
buy your mom I brought my mom and stuff
all the time throughout my career
look I wouldn't have known I was like
wow she's incredibly young I look
forward to meeting her thank you though
for doing what you did most importantly
but also for letting us help out that's
a really cool thing diamond everybody
I'm gonna grab J and get out of here I
think we're signing off let's say
goodbye
oh look J is still talking he has a tray
hos taco on his on I'm going on to Gary
Whitta has a show called animal talking
which is a talk show in Animal Crossing
I'm going to do that I think it's on
Wednesday and sting is on the show
gleb's drunk ladies and gentlemen I
don't have one I've never played deep
play my switch and I got a I just hooked
it up to my stream worth been talking
about playing it but I do know about
Danny because Danny and I person was
here and my person whatever but I know
he's been doing it a bunch so I want to
go
but it's so fun because my daughter is a
boarding school still so I've been
really like she's been working with
horses doing video games getting my
thumb's hurt in between the podcasting I
know I'm getting my time in you're
leaning into your inner geek I've been
doing this the IRL Kevin I do stuff I
build Legos on there and I play games
but I'm gonna play Animal Crossing I
think we can visit Ireland's already to
get a cold so we have to try to figure
it out maybe you'll see me unhurt pile
into her on mine and that isn't good
enough yes there it is see that rescue
island you can maybe find us on an
island on Animal Crossing very soon keep
that in your memory banks thanks for
hanging out folks
Thank You bees is now available go to
movies pop up calm boobies boobies pop
up calm if you want to come reserve your
space as of tomorrow the open for
business you can't just walk up to it
you got it reserved go to movies pop up
calm Derek I don't know where Derek is
but Derek's the genius behind all this
we thank him for including us and
creating this movies pop-up thanks to
everybody who showed up it was very okay
man
back to movies I know how awesome you
run thank you very much thank you very
much for being on my stream thank you
thank you guys that's I'll see you
tomorrow tomorrow's for Thursday yeah
tomorrow at 3 o'clock form you see you
tomorrow stitch to the new ch
you